US officials are going through sensitive
new intelligence recovered during a
daring raid in Syria that killed Isis
leader Abu Bakr al Baghdadi officials
say about 70 us commandos took off in
eight helicopters from a base in Erbil
Iraq Saturday night eastern time they
flew to a compound in Eid Lib province
of northwestern Syria where Baghdadi was
reported to be hiding US forces blew
holes in the side of the building they
say Baghdadi fled to an underground
tunnel with three of his children then
set off a suicide vest killing them and
himself five of Baghdadi's associates
were killed in the compound during the
raid and others died outside two of the
Americans suffered slight injuries
president Trump and other top officials
sat in the White House Situation Room
watching the raid as it unfolded CBS
News senior national security analyst
SATs Fran Townsend was a homeland
security and counterterrorism adviser
for president george w bush and joins us
at the table to discuss you know most
americans had heard of osama bin laden
many had not heard of mr. Baghdadi put
it in perspective about why his death is
such a big deal and what this means for
American strategy moving forward so Gail
it's a real blow to the movement writ
large not just the take out of Baghdad
II because remember bin Laden talked
about this notional Caliphate that one
day would be established Baghdad he
actually did it
and so this inspirational leadership the
actual establishment of a physical
caliphate was a big deal in the movement
he's good for that reason he's going to
be very hard to replace and American
forces and intelligence are now gonna
have to focus on the major nodes that
are left behind Afghanistan Somalia
Yemen Libya all of those have major
pockets and we're gonna watch a struggle
for who's gonna be the new Baghdady the
new leadership but as we've seen with al
Qaeda there's never really been one to
emerge so wajarri was a pale comparison
to bin Laden and it's always very
difficult when you have a real
inspirational leader to replace so it's
the u.s. safer today do you think with
him gone I do not only with him gone I
think Europe is also safer remember many
of the attacks
Isis launched were targeted were in
Europe not just the United States and so
I think the US and its allies are a
safer
there reports that the timing of this
raid was moved up because of the u.s.
withdrawal from Syria do you think
that's accurate well it would not
surprise me Anthony we've also heard
that there may have been one or two
other opportunities where they pulled
back I think US forces were concerned
that they were going to lose access to
the intelligence we know that they were
relying on the Kurds for intelligence
and once we were pulling out the turds
were suffering incursions from Turkey
and so I think that they were worried if
Baghdady moved in and they lost
intelligence they were going to lose the
opportunity entirely president Trump
thanked Russia for help in this raid
apparently some Russian territory was
flown over what's the significance of
Russia's involvement here you know Tony
what's happened is as the u.s. is pulled
back frankly across Syria what we've
seen is the Russians have filled that
gap and so it's pretty proud moment if
you're Vladimir Putin and the leader of
the free worlds got to come out and say
thanks for letting us fly over your
airspace you're feeling pretty good
about yourself I mean I really do think
what we're seeing is a resurgence of
Russia sort of in international
relations writ large all right Fran
Townsend thank you very much man we
appreciate it